north of england have been betrayed
because the prime minister made vet two
very important promises hs2
all the way uh to leeds a new line
that promise has been ripped up he also
promised the northern powerhouse rail a
new line from manchester to leeds and
that plans being ripped up this was the
first test of leveling up and the
government has completely failed and let
down everybody in the north and you
can't believe a word the prime minister
says
is the biggest yet and it will do more
quicker than the other club would have
what do you what do you say to that so
two things about that you don't have to
drill down very long into that 96
billion pound sum to realize that most
of that or a good deal of that is money
already spent on the bit of the line
that comes up uh to the midlands so that
argument doesn't hold water and as for
the improved um speed of time so of
course that's a good thing but if you
don't have a new line you don't sort out
capacity and that is the biggest problem
that we've got across the north so that
is i'm afraid just you know the tactics
of
of uh you know trying to ensure that
focus is on what's really happened here
which is the breaking of two very very
important um pledges and if you can't
level up uh in bradford
then the whole
leveling up agenda is seeing what it
really is which is just a slogan
in 2019 you set out a comprehensive plan
do you still stand by that
yes we set out a comprehensive plan for
hs2 and for the northern powerhouse rail
and we stick by that and that's the big
difference between us and the government
when we set out promises we stick to
them the government makes promises and
then it rips them up which is exactly
what it's done today